we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's pick back up with our caller from
the two-five 2 area code caller from - 5
- what's your name where you calling
from
hey my name is Sharon I'm from North
Carolina can you hear me alright yeah I
can hear you fine Sharon what's on your
mind ok great
well I've been watching ever since The
Whistleblower I stay at home and so I've
been watching youtube all the news clips
about Trump - steadily I mean everything
that they'll probably overdose on it but
my concern is that he is so crazy and
deranged at this point and citing his
followers to the point that what he just
did last night by overturning stone
sentence and the federal prosecutors
walking out I think ok so remember just
we want to be clear this sentence the
sentence hasn't even been handed down
yet nevermind overturned we want to be
clear that we know what Donald Trump did
was he influenced the recommendation of
7 to 9 years to be retracted but so far
no sentence has been given nor
overturned we want to be clear but I
understand the point you're making okay
yeah but anyway
Trump's getting again directly involved
just like he did with the Navy SEAL and
all these other people that he decides
to 70 if we don't do something now if
somebody doesn't do something now to
take him down a notch or let him know
that he can't get away with Singh and
it's gonna have to be somebody a whole
lot more than because I don't know how
you do that prism United States but I'm
just afraid before November even gets
here but something is going to happen
he's gonna have his supporters behind
him and you know his supporters have
guns and it's just they hate their
haters they are just crazy enough to do
whatever it takes to make sure
that chump gets what he wants that's a
listen here's mine you're not wrong
generally about the potential tendency
to violence of Trump supporters you're
not wrong about Donald Trump being
willing to go further and further and
further because why wouldn't he he's
gotten away with everything so far but
when you're looking for something to do
it's mid-february right we at this point
are only eight and a half months from
the election they're the fastest
solution is overwhelming the vote in
November by so much that the voter
suppression can't hand it to Trump that
the voter purges the meddling that we
have to overwhelm the vote to such
that's the solution and I know a lot of
people call in and where every day work
a day closer and there's folks still
looking for what can we do to get this
under control
we've just got to overwhelm the vote in
November that that's it and I've been
saying for years
impeachment won't get him out oh you're
gonna mount it I get it I get it yeah
everybody can do their part you get
somebody they know to flip or get them
just encouraged to go Bo yes right yes
and if everybody could just get one
person that thousands more if everybody
gets an on voter to go vote that doubles
turnout right I mean that's not that's a
we shouldn't underestimate the the
influence of that sharin a real pleasure
I appreciate the phone call Sharon from
Tennessee from North Carolina rather
hope to hear from you again